(pensive music)
- [Narrator] This Ukrainian crew
is driving a British Challenger 2 tank.
Kyiv's forces are training to maneuver,
(gun loading)
load ammunition and maintain
Western military vehicles ahead
of their delivery to the battlefield,
which the UK says could be weeks away.
So far in the war, both Ukraine
and Russia have been
using Soviet era tanks,
such as the T-72, but the UK
is one of several NATO members
including Germany and
the US that have offered
to send Western style tanks to Kyiv.
The Wall Street Journal
visited the Ukrainian troops
learning to operate
the systems to find out
the key technical differences
with Russian tanks.
- [Trainer] Reverse.
Keep the grips in.
(tank rumbling)
- [Narrator] The British Army
is taking the Ukrainian soldiers
through different stages of training.
They're currently three
weeks into the program.
First, let's look at maneuvering.
Some drills are being
taught on training tanks,
which don't have turrets.
- We are at the point
of the advanced sections
and that's more how to use the tank
in a tactical environment,
how fast you can move it,
how much it can take essentially
before you have to basically
rein it in a little bit.
- [[Narrator] Gregor
is a Ukrainian Soldier
learning these skills.
(Gregor speaking in foreign language)
(tank rumbling)
- [Narrator] The Challenger
2 tanks are slower
than the Soviet era T-72
vehicles, as they're heavier.
- Soviet era tanks are smaller and lighter
than Western tanks
so they'll find it easier
to get up a steep hill
because they weigh 45 or 50 tons
as opposed to about 70
tons of a Challenger.
- [Trainer] So when
you've got steep hills,
because the gun might dig into the floor
when you come down the hill,
sometimes you'll need
to stop and put the gun
over the side just to get down the hill.
- [Narrator] Then there's
the differences in firepower.
The Challenger 2 has a 120 millimeter
rifled barrel tank gun.
That means the inside of
the turret has grooves
while the T-72 uses what's
known as a smooth bore armament
which means it has a flat interior.
- In theory, rifling makes
the gun more accurate
but it also slightly slows down the round.
The T-72 has an auto loader
so there's a sort of circular cassette
of ammunition in the base of the turret.
- [Narrator] That's in contrast
to the Challenger 2, which
requires manual loading.
- There are four people who
operate a Challenger 2 tank.
We have a loader operator,
which is different
from the the tanks that
they have at the moment
because they have an auto
loader in their tanks
and we have a person to do that.
- [Narrator] The British Army
is training Ukrainian forces
to load the ammunition
using a simulator machine
called a loaders drill trainer or LDT.
This helps the crew practice
loading up the tank,
ready to fire.
(gun shooting)
- [Announcer] target.
Target stopped.
- The loader needs to
know how to get the big,
heavy 120 millimeter shell
into the breach of the gun.
Now, that just needs practice.
It's not a complicated task
but physically, it's quite challenging
and it's even more challenging
when the vehicle's in combat
and moving around.
- [Narrator] Ukrainian
forces are also learning
to maintain the vehicle
so they can run smoothly.
- We started off with
the maintenance phase
and the technical details
phase, to install components
how they work, every single
aspect of the tank essentially.
- [Narrator] Lessons include how to check
these rubber triangles
situated on the wheels.
They need regular checks during combat.
- Tracked vehicles do
break down more frequently
than a wheeled vehicle of similar size.
(pensive music)
- [Narrator] Overall, military
analysts say the readiness
of the Ukrainian forces will depend
on how quickly they can learn.
- Some of the Ukrainian armed forces
have operated tanks before
but most of them have not seen a tank.
- [Narrator] But getting to
grips with battlefield tactics
and the electronic systems
on board could be difficult
for those without prior experience
according to defense analysts.
The number of Western vehicles provided
could also be a hurdle for Ukraine.
Kyiv requested 300 western tanks
but defense experts say only around 50
to 60 have been offered so far.
Russian officials attacked
the pledges for tanks.
Kremlin spokesman Dmitry
Peskov said Moscow sees them
as increasing the West's direct
involvement in the conflict.
(soldiers shouting)
For the Ukrainian soldiers
training here in the UK,
the lessons could soon
be put into practice.
(pensive music)